When evaluating square roots or other even roots we can't take the root of a
negative number. That's because there's no number that can multiply two times,
or any even number of times, to have a negative sign. We know a negative times
a negative equals a positive number, so any number of two negative signs would
always be a positive. So we can't exactly simplify the square root of negative
1. We know it's not equal to negative 1, since negative 1 times negative 1
really equals positive 1. And, we also know that the square root of negative 1
does not equal positive 1 since 1 times 1 equals 1. There's no value in the
real number system that gives us the square root of negative 1. We'll need
something else for this. It turns out that we define it as i, an imaginary
number. I allows us to take the square root of negative numbers. For example,
if I wanted to take the square root of -4, I would split this radical up, into
the square root of -1, and the square root of 4. We know that the square root
of 4 is simply 2. And the square of negative 1 really equals i our imaginary
number. So, we get the products of 2i. for the second one we have the square
root of 3 times the square root of negative 1. This number really represents i.
So, we replace the square root of negative 1 with i. We leave the product of
the factor in front of the radical. So we'll have I times of the square root of
three, our final result. And for our last one, we'll have the square root of
negative one times the square root of 12. We can simplify the square root of 12
by breaking it up into the square root of four times the square root of three.
We know the square root of negative one is really equal to I. So we write that
here. And then we take the square root of 4 which is 2. We multiply these two
together to get 2i times the square root of 3. In a lot of ways we treat i just
like a variable. We list it after the product of any numerical factors but
before the radical sign. Now that we've seen a couple of cases of simplifying
negative radicals with i let's see if you have the hang of it.